la grande pyramide de Khéops nous
étonnant encore 4500 ans après sa
construction on vient d'y mettre à jour
un tunnel caché de 9 mètres de long et
de mettre de large tout juste derrière
l'entrée principale
c'est dans cette pyramide située à
proximité du Caire la capitale de
l'Egypte qu'a été enterré le puissant
pharaon il y a déjà découvert plusieurs
chambres et tunnels mais très peu
d'artefacts appartenant au souverains
probablement parce qu'ils ont été pillés
dans le passé
c'est un des mystères de la pyramide dit
se responsable des fouilles on a
retrouvé des artefacts de roi dans
toutes les autres pyramides mais pas
dans celle-ci
les archéologues égyptiens ont fait
appel aux experts de scan pyramides qui
ont d'abord utilisé des technologies non
invasives comme la thermographie
l'amiographie et les ultrasons pour
repérer le tunnel puis une minuscule
caméra pour enfilmer l'intérieur on
croit qu'une nouvelle chambre funéraire
se trouve au bout du corridor mais ce
sera difficile de le vérifier sans
ouvrir un passage dans la pierre ce qui
est exclu pour l'instant quand on ne
peut pas comme ça ouvrir un monument qui
est aussi vieux et que résister au
Millénaire aussi en étant aussi droit on
ne peut pas l'endommager ça a toujours
été le défi en fait avec les pyramides
en 2017 en 2020 puis en janvier dernier
le gouvernement égyptien a présenté
toute une série de nouveaux artefacts au
public les archéologues apprécient
l'économie égyptienne également pour les
touristes le mythe de l'Égypte ancienne
est certainement l'un des attraits les
plus importants du pays beaucoup
d'annonces qui ont été faites dans les
dernières semaines de momie de tombeau
etc ça garde cette espèce de fascination
très vivante effectivement les gens ont
tendance à se déplacer dans l'espoir
d'être sur place si on trouve quelque
chose aussi un nouveau tombeau puis ça
peut être ouvert au tourisme aussi au
public ici normand Grondin Radio-Canada
Montréal